- I'm obsessed with a video
I saw on Facebook recently.
It's a young girl who
got bullied for her hair,
and she wasn't having it.
Take a look.
(whooshing)
- So, yesterday, I went to school
and I wore my hair in a Afro, like this.
And a lot of people had
a lot of mean things
to say about it.
So, that made me feel some type of way.
I told my mom and she said,
"Promise, don't forget who you are,
and whose you are."
And I said, "okay."
So today, I'm gonna go to school
and I'm gonna come back bigger and better.
And don't allow anyone to steal your joy.
Don't give them that much power.
- Oh my God.
(crowd applauding and cheering)
All right, I see you.
Her name is Promise Sawyers,
she's only 10 years old,
but I want to make her my life coach,
'cause I love her.
Promise is here along with her mother Qui.
So, okay, Promise tell me what happened
when you got to school.
- So, when I went to school,
I wore my hair in a Afro.
And, a lot of people had a lot of
mean things to say about it,
and that really surprised me,
because at my other school,
everybody used to love it.
They would say, Promise, I love your hair.
But when I went to this school,
everybody just had several
negative things to say about it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's mean.
Kids can be mean.
Junior high sucked for me.
(laughing)
It wasn't fun.
But as moms, we try so
hard to protect our kids,
and I'm gonna be real with you.
I probably would have
walked up to that school,
I would not have handled that well.
Maybe lost a couple jobs.
'Cause it's your baby.
Somebody's talking to your baby
and they don't even know your baby.
They're just makin' fun of somethin'
that's maybe different
than what they're used to.
What'd you tell her when that happened?
- So, she came home, and of course
kind of expressed what happened.
She was like, I'm feelin'
sad, I'm feelin' this,
and she kind of gave me
like a plethora of emotions.
And admittedly, I wanted to defend,
and I'm like, no, no, no, Promise.
I had to stop her, we were
not having a pity party.
And I had to tell her, how
did you feel this morning?
How did you feel when you walked out?
And she said, I felt confident,
I felt good, I felt great
about it, I felt cute.
I'm like, okay, and she said,
but they said mean things
and they said this,
and then she just kept goin' in.
I was like, no, no, no,
how do we feel about it?
And she said, I felt good.
And I said, that's all that matters.
I said you're not going--
(applause)
- It's so great.
So who had the idea to create the video?
- So we went, kind of like
the end of that conversation,
when I told her I said
we're not going to allow
what someone says to
dictate our entire day,
you can give it a little
moment, but not the entire day.
And so, she said okay.
- [Kelly] You're such a good person.
(laughing)
- It takes practice--
- Can you write a book?
(laughing)
- And so, when she said
okay, it wasn't like,
okay I feel good about this,
it's kinda like, okay here's mom again.
But the next morning, I'm
just brushing my teeth,
and she's like, where's your phone?
I'm like, okay.
So, I came out from brushing my teeth
and just heard her saying those words.
And I was like, that is my kid!
- Yeah, and I really--
(applause)
- I'm so proud of you, that's so cool
that you flipped it, you
turned it into a positive,
you turned it into
confidence, I love that.
How did the kids react when
you went back the next day?
- They were kinda used to it,
but some people still were asking
why are you wearing your hair like that?
I was like--
- Why are you wearing your hair like that?
(laughing)
That's what I would say.
I love that.
Your video though has
inspired so many people,
including my first guest y'all.
She is a Golden Globe
award-winning actress,
and the star of "Black-ish."
The last time I saw her,
she was singing "A Moment Like This"
at the American Music
Awards, it was awesome.
Say hello to Tracee Ellis Ross, thank you.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Look at you, oh my God.
- Look at Promise, look at
Promise, look at Promise.
- [Kelly] Oh!
(crowd cheering)
- That is so beautiful!
- Promise, you're my dream!
- Get up here!
- Promise, come here.
- Come here.
- Come up here, yes!
Give her a hug.
(Promise sobbing)
- Do you wanna sit and do this with me?
Can she sit here with me?
- You can do anything
you want, it's my show.
(crowd cheering louder)
- Sure, she'll sit right here.
You can scoot down just
a little bit Promise.
- I saw your video, and I was so moved.
Because your hair is an
extension of your legacy,
what you come from, your story,
and everything that you
are, and your beauty.
And I'm so glad that
you knew at 10 years old
what it took me so long
to learn about myself.
And you are such an example.
Well done on the parenting.
- Well done.
Well done.
And you're very honest,
like on social media,
that's what I loved about you, Promise
she's actually the grown version.
She's very honest on social media.
You don't hide anything,
you're very proud of your body,
your hair, where you
come from, everything,
and I think that that's a beautiful thing,
and it's such a beautiful,
look how much you touch people.
- Thank you.
- Your hair looks gorgeous today, too.
Look at this.
- Thank you.
(crowd cheering)
- I like the braids, too.
Promise, do you want
to say anything to her?
All these women that stand up
for who they are and they're real,
they're not filtered all the time,
they're just exactly in
the raw, how they are.
Like, what do you want to say to Tracee
and all these women that do that?
- Just keep doing what you're doing,
and just go make the world a better place.
(crowd cheering)
- I'm happy to meet you.
- Oh my God, well Tracee--
- I'm done.
- This wasn't even expected,
I'm losing my mind, it's fine.
Anyway, Tracee, I love
this video of you as well.
We're gonna roll the tape here.
(whooshing)
- Last night's pasta dinner.
Dinner, right here.
Lunch.
And this is God-given.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- First of all, first of all,
I would die for that body!
You look so great in that video,
but I love that you were like,
this is mine, this is mine.
- Yeah, and this was lunch.
(laughing)
- That's my favorite part, with the belly!
But why is it important to you
to be able to stand up and be yourself?
Why do you feel like that's important?
- You know, this idea of
'I woke up like this,'
like at 18, at 10 years old, maybe I did.
But I work for this body, and this hair,
and this face, and all these
things at 46 years old.
And I also really feel
like Instagram and media
and social media can
create this image of us,
this curated image that
people think is real.
We as people, as human
beings, are these full beings,
that have good moments and bad moments,
bad hair moments, good hair
moments, and all these things,
and I feel like it's really helpful for me
when I see other people in their truth.
It makes me feel comfortable with myself.
- Totally.
- 'Cause there's all these things.
- So this was important.
(laughing)
This was important though, right?
This is amazing.
This is gorgeous!
- Thank you.
- It's gorgeous, it's beautiful,
it's hot, it's sexy,
it's all the adjectives.
- Thank you, and it's Essence.
- I want to borrow that.
I won't look like that in
it, but I want to borrow it.
- Yeah, that's what I just wear
to bed at night. (laughing)
- My husband dreams I did.
- Oh, I'm lyin'.
- Walkin' in in my flannels.
- I'm in my glasses, I like to tuck
my sleeping T-shirt into my underwear,
and then the pajama pants over that.
- Do you not want
anything to get in there?
- I don't like a draft when I'm sleeping.
- Oh my gosh, I'm opposite.
(laughing)
But what does being on the
cover of this mean to you?
'Cause that's Essence!
- It means a lot to me.
This is the fourth time that
I'm on this cover actually.
- That's amazing!
(crowd cheering)
- But Essence does such a beautiful job,
and has for decades
and years never ending,
of really representing our community
in such a beautiful way, in
all of our diverse beauty.
Curly, coily, and tight textured hair
was not always a part of
the culture of beauty.
Although we for decades and eons
have been wearing our
hair in its natural form,
there is a revolution of
celebration happening right now,
as people begin to understand the beauty
that has existed within us forever.
- Yeah, absolutely.